bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonale tv pour la suite de ces quarts
de finale de championnat du monde
féminin 2015 donc on a vu hier comment
un pic au nez rouge est bien avait perdu
sa première partie face à musi tchouk
maria nous y tchouk et puis comment
aussi et bien pogo nina qui avait battu
donc la vainqueur du match face à marie
sebag et bien avait perdu sa première
partie face à souza au donc des matchs
décisifs les autres matchs s'étant
soldées par des partis nul entre donc
pia crâne ling et la deuxième soeur la
soeur nous ichu cana et puis aussi entre
arica et indiennes et arabisé mairie la
géorgienne
donc c'était des matches nuls donc
aujourd'hui on va voir la suite des
événements des petits résumé rapide ici
dans la partie entre koné rond et maria
il faut donc que koné roulants portes à
la réussi à jouer une variante avec robe
de couleur opposée de couleurs de côté
opposé pardon grand roque pour les
blancs petit repos les noirs on a vu une
attaque de pions et noir ont pas réussi
à ouvrir le jeu contre le roi est là à
ce moment là on est au 32e coup collés
ou rentrer dans une finale regardez très
intéressant puisqu'elle fait tous rêver
cette une finale particulière puisqu'on
va donner deux tours contre une dame
alors souvent les débutants savent pas
trop s'il faut donner la deux tours
contre une d'avaler la règle c'est que y
en a pas ça dépend des cas voilà c'est à
dire que c'est des fois c'est bon des
fois c'est pas bon lacaune héros estimé
que c'était bon en tout cas il faut
qu'elle essaie de gagner puisque sinon
elle est éliminée
donc il faut qu'elle gagne à l'aller
blanc elle a joué sa chance à fond et là
elle va rentrer une finale à la dame
contre deux tours bon parfois c'est
moins bien parfois c'est mieux
très difficile à calculer mais au moins
ça lui donne des chances de gain
ici simplement les noirs prennent d'un
retour premier sur roy prendre là bon
c'est pas clair de savoir qui est mieux
bon ses pions peuvent être attaquées par
le cavalier en c3 notamment mais les
tours sont très fortes aussi attaqué le
roi blanc
il faut faire attention laurent noir est
un peu faible puisque cette position
quand même pas super safe
voilà donc elle a estimé qu'au nez rouge
était mieux pour elle bon c'est pas que
les reins la partie a continué park
avait laissé trois attaques donc ces
fameux de pions 3e 6 ans qui est tendu
mais le roi au centre mais bon on
protège des 5 voilà cavaliers prend ou
des six puisque le foot et elle a été
attaquée en revient en c3 et attention
elle met l'accent sur le fait que
l'autre pion est faible pour ces 8
bon maintenant en cas de prise attention
ça serait une faute un regard des sicav
allez prends simplement les noirs font
cavalier prend échec au roi fourchette
il faut prendre du plomb mais maintenant
la tour pas pour donc prendre la dame il
s'appelle un échec à la découverte ou
plutôt une attaque à la découverte ici
en quelque sorte donc toros et 8
on ne prend pas le public l'a tout de
suite mais on joue au roi 2 voilà il a
en menace de le prendre
quel et b6 protège
dames f2 aux menaces de rentrer dans le
camp noir et là on va faire des dégâts
parce que si on arrive à prendre ses
deux pions là par contre ça va faire la
différence à faut tenir
il faut jouer tous réfutent voilà
tranquillement dame eux deux maintenant
je menace de venir en b5 déstabilisant
le cavaly b6 s'il bouge il ya des cinq
qui tombe puisque le cavalier protège
aussi bon est-ce que c'est très très
grave pas forcément parce que les noirs
auraient pu jouer par exemple simplement
un couteau tour b8 très bien et bon
cavalier sur dame bessin bon le cas à
les protéger il n'y a pas de problème et
dessins qui reste protégé aussi alors
ici les noirs jouent un coup sans doute
déjà mauvais un tour à cinq mauvais coup
pourquoi parce que ben elle est mal
placé la tour déjà on voit sur la
colonne a là rien à faire le bon à part
être protégé le pion à 4 ce qui est
quand même pas un rôle extrêmement actif
puis la bombe et ces deux cas sont pris
par l'adversaire que ce soit par le
cavalier ou par le pion donc elle est
très mal placé sept tours et en plus
elle n'est pas protégée et puis alors si
on met les deux tours sur la colonne à
ces pour attaquer rien c'est juste pour
défendre donc c'est très passif donc
c'est pas une bonne idée sont toutes là
les blues jouent le magnifique île
simple rider 2 voilà attention claque le
fou attaque la tour voilà donc où un peu
imprécis des noirs qu'avait laissé 4
quand même à l'heure de tenir puisque
j'attaque le fou protéger la tour au
passage un mais il ya une astuce
magnifique conejo rate pas il faut rien
rater évidemment dans ce type de
position
cavalli 34 très jolie puisque scipion
prend et bien simplement d'emprunt ces
quatre échecs j'ai pris l'option dessin
et sans doute aux 4 va tomber aussi
puisque ça va être très difficile à
défendre à la dame va le prendre alors
là on aura deux pieds au centre au lié
passé fera sans nous donner une pièce ou
deux
pour le pour les empêcher d'avancer donc
après ça va être perdu faut quand même
garder l'équilibré de matériel l'ado
torvald adam mais pas pas si on commence
à donner du matériel ça marche l'une la
tour b 5 alors les noirs essai de contre
attaquer sur la colombe et menacent tout
reprendre les deux échecs fous ces trois
protège toi et ce v8 bien menace
pourquoi pas d'aller prendre en b2 et là
les blancs jouent très précis magnifique
car je les prends des six et ils ont pas
peur regardez la manoeuvre lui lance si
on reprend bon y'a pas de problème tout
est protégé b2 et se protéger mais là la
menace noire elle existe il fallait tout
calculé je vous rappelle qu'il faut que
les blancs gagne là nul ça suffit pas
tout reprend échec parce qu'après fou
prend tout reprend échec attaque la dame
on est obligé de donner la dame après
calais prof elle est sûre avec les
blanks a gagné cette finale mais oui
c'est gagné on reprend apprend
simplement on joue trois ces 2 6 3 alors
des deux sur nos marchés aussi c'est pas
le roi des trois est encore mieux sans
doute la 3f 5 pour empêcher le 4 mai le
quatrième échec que font les noirs il
faut prendre il ya pas le choix est
maintenant roi ou trois terminé si je
sors je prends le cas de gm qui ont
passé j'avance le plus au maximum quand
le roi est au bout j'avance ici et après
tout comme ses deux pions pas de
problème je fais dames 1 et si le nom et
les noirs viennent prendre les pions ici
c'est trop de c'est trop long je joue à
des 5
pour le même je prends jour en f4 je
sais pas voyons imaginons par exemple le
roi donc j'ai quatre ici simplement
voilà je prends en abordant si je pousse
et je ris curiel je ne prends pas le
pion parce qu'en cas de dams a fait
échec donc je viens en jus 3 par exemple
est simplement dès 6 h 4 17 h 2 h 8 donc
dame
heureusement qu'on n'a pas pris sinon
échec h2e mais là ça c'est pas bon ça
c'est pas bon du tout tout et tout est
bon pour lui blanc échec au projet 2 par
exemple d'un modric est croit g1
et simplement regarder trois en k2 dames
yamato f2 mais bien plus le roi est
proche donc voilà donc il fallait avoir
toute cette finale quand on joue
cavalier prendrait six donc allez prends
des six dames ces deux attention blue
blum
voilà on sai et en récupère du matos
cavaliers ou quatre fous b4 coupe
définitivement l'action des tours wife
funk et on prend même pas le pion à
quatre dames c6 vise g6 vise la case f6
visent potentiellement aussi le pion des
scènes par exemple si les noirs jouent
alors si les noirs jouent le set tourne
en bicis pour empêcher la dame de
prendre ici le pion des scènes tombe
avec échec qu'on peut avoir le cavalier
et si c'est l'autre tour
ça a l'air de tenir on se dit on n'a
qu'à mettre le tour mais ça marche pas
échec
ya pas qu il n'y a pas de coût pour le
noir le roi est pris donc on est obligé
de jouer tour 6 et simplement sa paire
la tour voilà donc après dame ces six
projets 4 ses forces et on vient me voir
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de réponse
on peut pas que faire avec les noirs ici
c'est le problème que faire comme s'ils
étaient jouées d'amd cette menace est on
vient de voir ses mates d'ailleurs si on
joue pas tomber s'ils sont nés
m'attendent 17
on est coupé de mon prix donc il faut
jouer roger 4 alors et ont purgé six
branches 4,25 cavale et j'ai trois dames
f4 échec faute précédant ce type final
c'est pas facile quand même il ya quand
même deux tours le 3g 600 mais cette
dame 5 h 4 pour les noirs bombay qui
essayent de aussi de créer un pion un
pion passé mais j'ai sept mois là ça y
est je suis plus qu'à une case de faire
dame je menace pas faux et fuite parce
que ça a l'air de bloquer mais attention
je me prends un match ici en b2 à un b 1
et la deuxième tour je me fais maths et
sur sur la petite sur mon petit espace
mon petit coin ici du roi nanan faut
faire attention rouages 2 simplement la
d'alger scène menace
j'ai huit dames ainsi que d'un projet 4
donc là les noirs jour tour g8
du coup là maintenant il n'y a plus de
matches ici j'aurais pu prendre h 4
aussi avec échec suivi de fouet fuite ça
a l'air bon pourquoi elle n'a pas fait
d'ailleurs dans prend h quatre échecs
puis il faut en fuite maintenant le fait
fouet le fait mais c'est ce qu'il fait
si si pardon c'est bien ça faux d'en
prendre quatre échecs
roger 2 et la foulée suite voilà la tour
était prise au piège
ça y est ça c'est bien on va jouer d'un
match 7 si les noirs font rien donc ça
va gagner une pièce donc il faut faire
un tour prend g7 et vous allez voir
comment finissent à faut prendre tout
reprend la main en dames contre tours et
cavaliers avec des pions servait pas de
pionsat frais nul on peut faire nul mais
avec des pions non là ça va aller donc
dans des huit déjà le pion des 5es perdu
tu as you can en prend bref trois de
cinq attaques la tour donc tour
tiens je reviens ici oui on peut pas oui
d'un médecin y marche pas parce qu'on
fait roi prendront un tour dans les cinq
attaques la tour tour g4 est là
simplement échec
là on est obligé de venir en g3 sinon on
perd la tour et maintenant des 5 lots
peuvent rien faire contre l'avancée de
ce pion
si le câble et vient des six centres on
perd par dame eux cinq échecs et le
cavalier perdu les noirs jouent encore
tour h4 et après des six il abandonne
voilà les noirs peuvent rien faire la
menace et 17 comment voulez vous paraît
ça la dame contre le beaucoup trop de
cases ce cavalier prend d'un échec puis
d'un prend il reste en plus encore
d'options mais même de toute façon
roi-dame contre retour ça gagne
techniquement à tous les coups donc
voilà magnifique victoire de koné roues
dans cette partie à sens unique
elle a réussi à garder toutes ses
chances donc elle a joué des robes de
couleurs opposées ce qui est très bon
pour essayer de gagner
et puis on le voit deux tours contre une
dame elle rend dans une position
asymétrique les noirs cafouille
il aurait très bien pu tenir ses
positions mais il fallait être précis
mais il cafouille et après on en profite
l'a réussi en profite et profite d'une
erreur petit une petite erreur tactique
magnifique vision de finale on l'a vu il
y avait des finales possible mais à la
fin c'est bien et finale gagnante il
faut toujours vérifier parce que ça
pourrait être des finales nul donc et on
peut pas se permettre
il faut ici il faut gagner la partie
donc la très très bien calculé très bien
joué
magnifique retour donc on aura droit à
un tie break dans ce premier match alors
deuxième match alors pour voir le
deuxième match on va simplement
ici pareil voire la position cruciale
alors elle nous joue pogo nina qui a les
noirs dont tu dois essayer de l'emporter
puisqu'elle a perdu hier une c1 qu'elle
aurait pu tenir on en a parlé finale de
couffouleux couleurs opposées a choisi
un mauvais plan en plus l échange des
tours de façon non forcées mais même en
changeant les tours en fait il ya un
plan de nul
j'ai donné les clés hier c'est à revoir
mais en détail mais en gros il fallait
que le roi protège l'avancée du pur h si
vous revenez sur cette position
il aurait fallu que le jour où un f3 au
lieu de roide et 5
si vous revenez dans cette partie si
vous regardez la vidéo que vous menez la
partie roi f3 du droit des scènes dans
la finale de pions il fou permettait
simplement aux blancs de tenir il suffit
de mettre le roi sur la case achat et
ensuite on sacrifie le fou contre les
pions a et b puis qui doivent s'échanger
d'abord contre le pion mais bon bref je
revienne pas dessus mais elle aurait pu
tenir natalia pogo l'ina dans cette
finale et donc faire nul avec les noirs
avec les blancs pardon mais là
maintenant les noirs et doit essayer de
gagner pas évident face à un sou à eau
qui est favorite en plus de ce
championnat du monde en fait avec koné
roues très certainement maintenant que
les autres stars se sont fait éliminer
ces cinq ouvertures tendue des 5 et l'a
très bien très bon choix pour ces gagner
avec les noirs bien sûr le fameux gambie
banco voilà enfin le gambit bengo bessin
qu'on sacrifie le pion b et contraint le
pion c'est avec l'idée d'éloigner un
pion du centre et on va ouvrir des
colonnes ici pour les taper sur les
pions b et à vous allez voir comment ça
se passe
qui on prend à 6 puis on prend g6 on se
presse pas de prendre le pion puisqu'on
a tout le temps là on se développe
regardez vous montre l'idée de ce début
voilà on prend du cavalier pourquoi pas
on aurait pu prendre de la tour du fou
bon mais de cavalli je pensais bien ses
classiques puisque l'idée c'est que
après d'un v6 tout cavalier c'est cette
voie on sort d'abord la dame est
maintenant je reviens c'est cette île
est bien ce cavalier tapis si parfois il
peut venir en dessin pour venir en d4
il fait pression sur
décès l'on veut que les blancs jouent
aux quatre donc des 5 on peut faire
pression par aussi par fougue et s'est
augmenté la pression au maximum les
blancs tôt ou tard ajouté cas voilà donc
cette case est faible galfond et parfois
ainsi le cavalier arrivants b 5e puis
des quatre on aura avec l'idée du feu
avec le foot
une pièce très forte en d4 on a donné un
pion mais on a du jeu cavaliers 17 1 4 x
6 x 6 alors attention on peut jouer
cavalier vaisselle maintenant puisque
sur pions prg n'ont pas pu ou non peut
pas je sais pas mais c'est une erreur
je pensais ou vous jouez avec cavaliers
prend en fou prend ça marche pas il ya
une tour et tour mais mais simplement
prendre pions voilà donc ici simplement
tour à 3 alors on met la tour ici sur
une case où elle est trop tg1
et aussi on contrôle pourquoi pas la
troisième manche demande sur ce très
intéressant ici mais ça contrôler la
case b3 et voilà ça y est tu aurais fait
8 les noirs ont fini de développer
toutes leurs pièces
regardez donc ces c'est l'idée de cette
ouverture j'ai sacrifié ce ses deux
pions la faire un seul pion un pion b
pour faire pression maximale sur cette
colonne b et les blancs peuvent pas
vraiment bougé ce pion voilà ils sont
sous pression
dams et de cavaliers cinq échanges
jeunes cavaliers vous prend
des 4b rouillé on a échangé un défenseur
de la case des quatre câbles et d un
protège ici alors ça peut être l'idée
c'est qu'on joue peut jouer peut-être
fou 3d fois pour contrôler la case 4 et
on a mis le carrier à défense de b2o 6
très fort pression sur le centre
voilà pression sur le centre que font
les blancs alors si les blancs prennent
bah c'est pas c'est pas bon prise prison
prend du pion voilà tout simplement et
six f4
on joue sous des 4 et e5 qui a l'air
d'être bon puisque ces attaques la tour
maintenant on joue des 5
les noirs sont très très forts des pions
ils sont très très bien placés sous des
deux coups des quatre pour mot nina
précis où ces 3 au 5 août très très bien
positionné lmnp voilà ça y est c'est
fini cette classe d iv et super forte et
on joue aux cinq que si on a mis le feu
devant voilà si le temps que le foot est
derrière mais non coupable 5
voilà donc les normes très très bien
joué cette ouverture avec une belle
position
bon les blancs peuvent tenir mais bon
ils sont quand même un sous pression
maximale
ils sont resserrées pour un pion alors
fois je crois à l'idée c'est que
messieurs rumba le fou est bouché donc
on l'aqtim entretien trois sets où j'ai
4 to b cette alarme triple voyez comme
c'est la pression est maximale se presse
pas alors bon si c'est pour jouer tous
âges trois fusées cas de fouet de autant
il aurait fallu jouer fonds ftp c'était
mieux
la noire n'accepte pas les changes ou c4
voilà vous c4 laisse le fou ne pas
savoir où aller finalement c'est bill
pas terrible ce fou puisqu'il est sûre
il tape sur ses propres pions c4 à noter
que une petite batterie on ne sait
jamais bon il ya le cavalier là qui
tiennent tout un mais
et c'est pas si fin pour l'aimer pour
les blancs regardez les tours sont pas
liés ça fait peur vous prend dans prend
choisi de reprendre de la dame elle
aurait pu ici pogo nina reprendre du
pillon avec une petite astuce en cas de
fou prend ces quatre cas les rebonds
simplement donc du coup ben là c'est pas
bon pour les noirs si on donne un pion
mais il ya une astuce soir des dames b4
attaque la tour et le fou ça va leur
forme mais les blancs on pouvait prendre
à 6
on prend la tour avec échec le foudre
vient ou juste à temps on a donné que la
qualité contre deux pions donc met la
pression sur la colombie est forte je
pense c'est quand même bien pour les
noirs
qualité en plus il ya de quoi s'activer
il ya du jeu quand il ya du jeu du jeu
on va pouvoir faire cavalier à six qui
avaient les b4y avait laissé simples
pions des va avancer ça a l'air bon
ça a l'air très très bon bon bref fou
prend des quatre d'en prendre quatre
tours à deux donc tour à deux jeux sur
protège la case b2 on sait jamais les
noirs pouvaient sacrifier la qualité
peut être est on sûr protège c'est pas
plus mal façons les blancs ça fera que
jouer ils sont complètement vis et
regardez comme ils sont sur leurs trois
rangées alors que les pièces noires sont
magnifiques les tours b
le fou à 6 à tout moment ces trois peut
se jouer avec un vis-à-vis de fou le
cavalier va pouvoir s'amuser bon regarde
d'ailleurs s'amuser au regard des
cavaliers 8
alors c'est quoi l'idée vous allez voir
prix qu'avait laissé trois des blancs
tour b 4 pourquoi pas autour d un
attaque la dame d'un v6 on revient en v6
on garde les trois ici à 5
pas mal c'est un cas intéressant là les
noirs ne joue pas le coût d'un bessette
qui serait sans doute une faute donc se
trompent pas puisque y aurait très
certainement le très joli très fort car
il ya quatre à la fois protège b2 juste
à temps juste à temps et menaces
qu'avaient les v6 qui coupe la
communication entre les pièces voilà
qu'elle est bicis on coupe la
communication et le cavalier là
n'est pas en 17 pour s'échanger voilà
donc voyez donc sur à cinq dames c'est
cette pourquoi parce que sur cabaye à
quatre baies peut-être je peux prendre
le pion à 5
peut-être je laisse les tours en liaison
donc tour des nains ont sur protège ici
là l'idée maintenant c'est de menacer
callas 4 parce que sur dame prend bien
j'enlève le cavalier et les deux tours
attaque la dame et le fou pour cavaliers
6 juste à temps regardez cavaliers à 4
j'ai pas peur de dame prend maintenant
puisque je peux revenir ce qui n'était
pas le cas quand je n'avais pas les deux
tours liés je peux revenir en attaquant
à la fois la dame et le fou cela devient
une pièce il ya juste attendre car les
17,9 en cas de cavalli b6 bon ben je
pourrais échanger les valeurs pas tout
de suite parce que calais b 6
calais prend qui on prend et je prends
de ce que je veux je perds le jeu perd
le x 6 puisqu'il est attaqué par deux
tours donc je prends pas sur calais b si
je ne prends pas avec le cavalier je
joue pas jojo pogo vni d'ajouts c'est
pas moi heart tour tourbe et 7 pour les
noirs voyez donc c'est un bon début de
partie est le gambit benko très
intéressant très bien joué des noires en
magnifiques mais les blancs se
débrouille bien regarder un si cette
manoeuvre est forte elle est pas mal bon
ce pion est quand même passé
oui d'intérêt pas échanger les fous
c'est que le x 6 bloquent l'avancée du
pion aussi voilà ce puits on n'est pas
passé en tout cas elle est bloquée donc
en n'ayant pas échanger les fous de
classe blanche j'ai un bloqueur en même
temps en même temps que j'ai un
défenseur du pion c4 et donc ça se joue
à desceller subtilité positionnelle
fortin
tours à quatre tours en 1 4
forcée d'un point 4 et maintenant les
noirs font quand même tour car l'épreuve
et 6 à prendre et si c'est tout reprend
voilà je protège de la tour et de ne pas
d'emprunt sinon je perdais le fou voilà
mais les blancs ont très bien vu la
suite
simplement il joue tour 6 1 voilà
torcéen très bien pression 1 2 3 sur ces
quatre là les noirs trouve une jolie
défense dame csn pas mal
regardez ce qui se passe en france et 4
ohms menace matt menace d'un programme
de rachat d'emprunts en âge de maths et
là les blancs s'ils protègent elles
n'ont pas trop le choix pour protéger
d'ailleurs il faut jouer touré fin août
ours et de la limite pour ces deux epci
possible aussi mais c'est pareil pour
ces 2 ou touré fin le foot sur touré fin
le fou c4 est perdu et surtour ces deux
le fou c4 aussi des perdus il suffit
d'échanger les tours voilà et les noirs
sont gagnants voilà là ils sont gagnants
il n'y a pas de problème une pièce de
plus nette en plus sauvegardé les pions
sont sur blanc avec un fou mais c'est
même pas la peine 1 foot + ça suffit
largement donc la dame c5 et la très
jolie des blancs b3 pas mal ça rend coup
sur coup dans cette partie v3 et bien
voilà si on peut pas prendre du plomb
puisque la dame est perdu et qu'est ce
qui se passe sur seront prendre la
tourbe et le fou est perdu voilà donc la
b3 à l'air de gagner définitivement
l'option c4 en effet après alors fou b5
attaque la dame damas huit échecs g7
et puis on prend ces quatre et je vous
rappelle que les blancs eu nul leur
suffit puisqu'ils ont gagné donc avec
les noirs hier une finale que les noirs
avant que les blancs aurait pu annuler
comme on l'a vu légèrement comme je lé
rappeler en début de commentaire
x 6 donc les noirs c'est pas fini parce
que les pions sont sur blanc donc le
fouet de cases blanches les bons ce fou
pour attaquer sa celui-là il est que
défensif
d'accord la voile alors jouons fossiles
non plus la dame est un peu loin de
l'action alors on sait jamais la mort
peuvent pénétrer dans le camp ennemi
il faut faire attention que faire avec
les blancs c'est pas évident imaginons
que les blancs jouent un coup de type
j'ai pas madame des huit tient les
galères un bon coup un des 8 d'accor ont
peu joué par être tout simplement de
tourbe et deux attaques le fou et
attaqué deux derrière comment on défend
pas évident regardez il ya une défense
compliqué en fait on peut jouer la tour
ici en cas de prise du fou on peut jouer
la tour en f3 protège f2 et menaces à un
perpétuel là bas un échec perpétuelle le
fameux chèque perpétuelle mais si les
noirs le syli blanc le voit pas c'est
pas évident de voir ça à plusieurs
coupes distancé
si on joue roi et fun par exemple pour
protéger le fou et bien simplement dam
des quatre essais terminés
la troupe il ya trop de menaces un peu 4
est en prison peut jouer aussi dans des
deux à noter aussi que le fou quand il
va prendre ses 4 il y aura des cloisons
y aura des menaces de maths
par exemple si on joue tour ou si on
fait d'apprendre des six tient les en
essayant de faire en perpétuelle bien
les noirs
simplement peuvent jouer par exemple
coup très joli et inattendu
pas facile à voir pousser vite up menace
h trois échecs
s'ils ont bien eu un mais on se prend
dam des deux matches et s'ils ont bien
en géant on perd le fou suivi d'une
attaque de maths
donc voyez c'est très très chaud ça a
l'air de rien mais on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi sans que les noires
s'activent fort fortement donc les
blancs ici en fait tu trouves pas de cou
en fait c'est ça le problème donc pas
trop évident donc il joue autour de 1
voilà ils disent mais c'est pas grave je
vais lice espions finalement parce que
tout ça a l'air très pénible mais oui
parce que c'est passive malgré le pion
de plus c'est passif
les noirs sont bien sûr les cases noires
qui sont faibles et voilà de retour es
j'ai un oeil par transparence sur le
pian 2 4 et j'hésite eux je me dis je
vais échanger les fous très bien ça me
fait pas peur mais les noirs ne prennent
pas il fonde un bep quatre attaques la
tour 3 f1 je protège on n'aime pas quand
même mettre le roi sur la mini one elle
trouve c'est sûr que l'on n'aime pas ça
les noirs prennent foot renforcer
quasiment d'en prendre j'ai de bons soit
leur bon on se dit c'est tranquille bah
non c'est pas tranquille regardez c'est
équilibré mais qui a les pièces active
c'est les noirs regarder le renoir lui
il est tranquille tandis que lui un peu
moins
ce pion 4 et moitié en l'air pour le
protéger si je voulais protéger
définitivement peut jouer 3 mais dans ce
cas l'aja faibli le roi a terriblement
si je joue f3 tourbe et deux échecs
subis du suivi de maths rapide donc
c'est ça tient masse on voit que sa
position de chaîne un peu moins stable
bon ça a pas l'air trop grave mais
regardez magnifique tomber un superbe
tomber un superbe coup vu par godina
s'il est blanc près de la tour s'ils
apprennent pas si joe torre 3 ils vont
se prendre un match on va le voir mais
si près de la tour d'un prend 1,4 échec
puis je prends la tour je gagne un pion
j'ai la nuit un pion puis le pion on va
pouvoir avancer pour casser la position
du roi bon c'est tendu peut-être qu'on
peut quand même le faire cette pause i7
party tour prend bien dans prends mes
bons surtout sur dame prend où va le roi
parce que s'il vient sur la première je
prends un bain avec échec s'il vient sur
age 3 je peux même me faire mater plus
tard même avec juste une dame si
j'arrive à le monter par là avec les
pions je peux le matin et on sait ce
qu'on va avoir un petit peu avec la tour
imaginons que la tour maintenant
viennent à eux trois
regardez un match fort ces dames échec
le roi est obligé de venir avec trois
dames h un échec il faut venir angers
cas puisque si les blancs viennent en f2
eh bien regardez c'est échec et mat
la dame contrôler toutes ces cases et
les pièces touré pions empêche le roi de
bouger donc il faut venir à angers 4 et
là ça va être un match rapide puisque
simplement fait d'un proche de menaces
matt et c'est le même date c'est le même
mac parce que regarder la dame
protégerait attaquerez toutes les dames
et puissent toutes les cases et 7 cas
serait prise par le pion et celle là par
les blancs donc les leroy serait ce ce
serait mal donc d'un proche de il faut
revenir en fait ici on n'a pas le choix
en kf3 simplement et maintenant on
refait d'un machin là c'est fini
qu'on aille là où là on se prend un acte
son âge 5,61 de la dame donc voyez vous
tombez 1 qu'est-ce qu'on fait quoi là
tout est attaquée quand même hein alors
essayons de voir si je prends bien d'un
échec au fn je prends et 6 3 h3 je
prends avec échec
donc j'ai gagné un petit on est dans une
finale de dames où le roi noir ne risque
pas vraiment des chèques et donc les
blancs vont souffrir et voire même ils
vont perdre donc la roi h3 simplement je
peux simplement prendre ici mais je
perdrais pas le pion des six puisque je
pouvais pouvoir revenir au f5 avec un
échec voilà donc les blés noirs gagne
plus on est dans une finale de dame
probablement gagnante pour les noirs
même si ça paraît c'est pas facile à
gagner finale dames en général mais là
dans cette position on peut considérer
que oui c'est sans doute gagnant parce
que le renoir ne risque pas de se faire
prendre des échecs perpétuelle
il est trop bien il a trop de
possibilités de se cacher et les pions
les plus centraux vont avancer
la dame soit le garde des cinq si elle
perdait 5 ça fera deux pions non c'est
pas possible donc tourbe et un mine de
rien mais damascène qu'un seul coup seul
pour l'épauler blanc et la regarder
tranquillement pogodin dame d'être en
patois même idée tu prends je vous
prends avec échec
pas facile
que je voulais blanc
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas de coût de
n'a pas beaucoup d'attentes si on joue
la dame regarde et on est pris par tous
faut garder contact avec la tour
si on joue tour trois ans prend la même
dame 1 f1 et c'est matt de la même façon
donc soit si on joue un pion on va
affaiblir le roi qui est déjà pas
terrible
le seul coût que true blood souza
auxerrois h3 regardez donc les blancs
sont en quasi eu besoin en fait c'est
magnifique tour b2 mesnac le roi étant
h3 mais j'attaque le pion mégane de
temps hélas les blancs ça fait quoi
faire comment protéger alors si je
protège par dame à 7,6 encore c'est
encore jouable balle et noir peuvent
jouer très certainement sans doute d'un
f3 tient à metz 3 1 peuvent aussi tour
deux procès d' attaquer le pion aux
cadres mais d'un bel trois c'est mieux
sa garde la pression sur e4 et ça laisse
le roi blanc d'une position très
inconfortable
cela est bon on a bien envie de passer
de pousser g5 j'ai quatre échecs il peut
se passer des trucs j'ai pas si la démat
force est là dessus mais ça y ressemble
ça y ressemble donc c'est quand même
extrêmement délicat surtout quand on est
en commence à être encore un peu en
crise de temps on sait pas trop quoi
faire donc la tour b 2 les unes blanc
sentent que ça chauffe
alors ils vont essayer de jouer leur
chance par un échec perpétuelle c'est
toujours le risque c'est à dire un échec
échec échec où on peut pas s'en sortir
donc il veut jouer aux dames c'est cette
belle idée bon je te laisserais tenter
des trucs mais moi je vais tenter de
faire d'emprunt chez d'emprunt ya pas
échec mais on en prend puis d'emprunt
échec et avec une tentative de
perpétuels mais les noirs ne craque pas
tranquillement au niveau et vas-y tout
reprend 1,2 à toi d'en prendre des six
alors attention 600 tombes
il ya peut-être des perpétuelles ou en
tout cas des possibilité d'annuler plus
forte pour les pour les blancs qui sont
quand même en difficulté notamment parce
que le roi est très très très très mal
placée très jolie de la part des noirs
ici envers nez tranquillement magnifique
dame c3
petit coup pas facile à voir chatah que
je défends le sait j'attaque la tour car
là il y aura plus de perpétuelle parce
que si je prends la tour soudain prends
je mets la tour en abscisses et c'est
fini voilà j'ai une tour de plus nette
que j'ai activé tout ça il ya pas de
problème et je menace par exemple dame
en b2 imaginons que la tour viennent par
exemple en jeu ses pattes ya un an j'ai
un chien ou en cas d'accord ah oui donc
il ya même la vraie menace
on peut la voir dans la partie en fait
la dame c3 les blancs empêche d'en b2
qui est une menace aussi attaque donc là
taux est attaquée fall a bougé de toute
façon tomber un mais c'est pareil si
l'avion j'ai en fait la vraie menace
c'était la double menace était dame c8
vois la magnifique échec superbe
incroyable incroyable la partie que nous
a sortis pour ghosn il a quand même
fantastique d'un bingo pression maximale
aucune faute
les blancs ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu ils
ont gardé tout le temps le pion de plus
mais l'activité noir se révèle plus
forte extraordinaire et l'abandonnent
on la semaad forcé en fait imaginons que
alors s'il est une blanche ou rouach
quatre qui vont se prendre au tour prend
h deux échecs on va le regarder
regardez tout simplement on va prendre
aux h4 tout reproche deux échecs projet
5 et simplement le petit h6 match
tranquille
matt tout est pris
ici c'est pris par le roi tout est
protégé par le roi la sepri hélas par
l'adam la sepri par la tour par le pion
et par la tour et enfin ici par le pion
aux cinq seimat jolie maths par le pion
aux 6 et si même s'est vite l'autre coup
c'est de jouer g4 il ya quand même des
cartes qu'il faut regarder
g4 et bien simplement revient dans ses
trois échecs et latour contrôle donc le
roi est obligé de revenir encore une
fois en 24 et simplement tout reprendre
et c'est quasiment la même âge 6 échec
et mat
et puis on contrôle les cases leroy
protège tout est ici la tour contrôle
est ici toujours pareil le pion et 5 et
le pion blanc empêche le roi devenir
angers 4 incroyable magnifique victoire
donc avec les noirs de peau goni d'un
c'est quand même
c'est comme une force classe est joueuse
on l'a vu face à marie sebag aussi comme
ça de revenir ça fait deux fois qu'elle
revient alors que on sent que l est il
sans doute éliminer non non elle revient
alors pour finir on va regarder quand
même les deux autres matches donc on va
avoir deux tie-breaks aux premières
tables coni roux fera un tie break face
à maria bouzouk souza ou sera obligé
aussi de faire un tie break face à
natalia boghni n'a enfin en or à pia
cramer ning face à ana cette fois musi
touques qui est plus jeune de deux ans
de maria que maria donc franc aussi en
taille mais un tie break puisque fait
nul à la première et enfin béhary
qualifier voilà america s'est qualifié
en gagnant aujourd'hui face à arabiser
c'est la surprise de ce tournoi
l'indienne donc on a deux indiennes
toujours en lice et deux ukrainiennes
donc c'est un match and ukraine ne l'a
pas vraiment qu'on a et on a une
chinoise pour arbitrer mais aussi aux
russes voilà donc c'est puis à pia
cramer on sait jamais chaque rame ling
qui est toujours là aussi voilà donc à
rica qui a battu aujourd'hui mairie
aramide et qui se retrouve qualifié la
seule qualifiée après les parties
longues pour les demi finales de ce
championnat du monde passionnant et qui
encore nous tenir en haleine pendant
bonne une bonne dizaine de jours
la finale se déroulant d'ailleurs en
plus en quatre parties je crois un
quartier quatre parties voilà donc
superbe superbe
match retour de quart de finale on aura
droit donc à des tie-breaks merci de
m'avoir suivi sur diagonale tv et à la
prochaine
au revoir